Monday night on the communicators
Republican FCC Commissioner Ajit PI
discusses key topics being considered by
the FCC including the speed of broadband
deployment across the US mr. pie is
joined by brian fung washington post
technology reporter broadband deployment
really is one of the key drivers of job
creation and economic growth one of the
things i found striking is that in the
21st century there has really been a
democratization of entrepreneurship
everywhere from Sioux Falls to Bozeman
Montana I've seen people who are using
that broadband connection to build
businesses that in a previous era either
would have had to migrate to one of the
coasts or would have withered on the
vine but because of that connection
they're now able to innovate and I think
that's something that's really powerful
especially in rural America watch the
communicators Monday night at 8 p.m.
Eastern on c-span
2
welcome to Hartford Connecticut on
American history TV the state capital is
one of America's earliest cities founded
in 1637 by Puritan settlers today it's
nicknamed the insurance capital of the
world with the help of our comcast cable
partners over the next 90 minutes will
hear a slavery story with ties to the
city what we're looking at here is the
cover of this great autobiography
written by venture Smith in 1798 this is
the earliest known african-american
literary voice and it's one of the great
masterpieces of American literature and
later learn about the role Hartford
played in the Civil War we are looking
at the beautiful soldiers and sailors
Memorial arch dedicated to the 4,000 men
from Hartford who fought in the Civil
War Hartford was also home to a vibrant
literary community we'll visit the home
of author Harriet Beecher Stowe
but first learn about Mark Twain and his
role as a father and husband when Mark
Twain moved to Hartford Connecticut it
was a very wealthy town it was
supposedly the at that time the richest
city in the nation per capita Mark
Twain's legacy here today it attracts
people from everywhere they get to come
inside this house and sort of time
travel back to a different time
Samuel Clemens we know today as Mark
Twain Samuel Clemens was a boy born in
Florida Missouri grew up in Hannibal
Missouri along the banks of the
Mississippi River back in the 1830s 40s
50s when his dad died he was only 12
years old and Sam had to be apprenticed
out as a typesetter and I don't know
that that began his love affair with
words but it certainly influenced a lot
of things later in his life when Mark
Twain began looking into Hartford as a
place to settle with his young wife and
their new family of course his publisher
Elisha bliss was here with American
publishing and he came to the city fell
in love with it really and just was
tickled to death wrote letters back to
his own family you know mother and
brothers and said this place is
beautiful
he bought the land Livie did have a
major inheritance that she would use her
money then to build the house and
decorate it so they built it in stages
when they moved in in 1874 the
Carpenters weren't quite done the
plumbers weren't quite done but they
were done enough that the family could
come in and take residence so they were
mainly on the second floor for a while
but ultimately they continued to work on
the home they traveled to Europe
frequently made purchases there that
they sent back to the home to furnish it
and and get it up to speed I'm excited
to welcome you into the master bedroom
this is Sam and Lili Clemens bedroom
this amazing bed is hand-carved of black
walnut it was made in Italy the family
paid $200 for it when they purchased it
which was a lot of money in those days
it's got a lot of unique features
specifically the headboard which of
course if you notice Sam Clemens and his
wife slept facing that headboard it
really is that spectacular that you
would want to wake up looking at it
rather than leaning your pillows against
it but probably the best feature the one
that I like the most is that the little
cherubs on each corner of the bed are
removable now the three daughters were
allowed to come in and remove these
these wonderful little cherubs I've got
to wear my white gloves here they do
lift right off and they were allowed to
play with them as though they were
little dolls
and bathe them and powder them and dress
them and all those sorts of things and
just enjoy having these little angels
but then at the end of the day Sam
Clemens insisted that they be put right
back on top of the bed he said you could
play with him all day but he wanted them
back on at bedtime when he went to bed
he said he thought that was the closest
he would ever come to being surrounded
by the angels so we know that the girls
did get a lot of mileage out of them
also very interestingly we have of
course gas lighting in this house it was
very modern at the time Sam Clemens did
read in bed he wrote in bed and of
course he smoked in bed and he raped up
an extension cord on the gas line so it
rented it what would be right here by
his bed as he worked in the evening or
read and a lot of people worried when
they say well didn't he smoke in bed yes
he did luckily at that time of course it
was low density gas and he really wasn't
endangering the family he wasn't going
to cause an explosion of any kind so
here in the master bedroom we have Sam
Clemens mother here Jane Clemens and no
there are no photographs of his father
his dad died in 1847 and photography was
not affordable for a family like that at
that time but of course here in the wall
we have the four children now baby
Langdon in the lower right corner did
not live in the Hartford house but we do
have his photograph here he died at 19
months of diphtheria
but then the other three daughters Susie
Clara and Jean are here on the wall in
mama and Papas room so it's fun to
imagine this as a family home with the
little girls running and playing and
calling for stories and all the things
that they did and of course growing up
to become young ladies here in this home
now the girls had a lot of adventures in
this home the family of course dined in
this beautiful dining room and would
come in to the library here after dinner
in the evenings and this was a very
special spot for instance the paintings
across the top of on the walls here and
the knick knacks on the mantel they
would ask for a story and the rule was
he had to begin with the cat and the
rough painting on the very end you have
to start there and they had these
certain rules from there he had to
continue across the mantle and
incorporate each and every nickname
and he could not go out of order and he
could not repeat himself and then he
would have to end with the painting of
Emmaline and that was that would satisfy
the girls the stories here in the house
the girls you know would recount as
young adult women that that was one of
their favorite things that they could
come in this room and have this
wonderful story time with her father a
conservatory a little bit of a jungle
this is what the little girls caught at
the daughters called at the jungle and
Papa Sam Clemens would get down on all
fours
George Griffin the butler also would get
down on all fours and the girls would
jump on their backs and they would go
hunting for tigers in the jungle and
have big adventures and expeditions in
here this was a favorite spot for the
family but it was a busy place very
famous guests would come to visit they
had fancy dinners in the evening if they
didn't you know the family of course
would be around the table themselves
were Sam Clemens was known to get up
between courses and pace and almost try
out his material you know he was well
lecturer he was often on the road
lecturing so he would tell these stories
again and again the girl said they could
stake would sneak down some nights and
sit on the steps out here in the hallway
and they could tell from where papa was
in his story what course was being
served but this is just some of the the
feel of the family we are on the third
floor of Mark Twain's beautiful Hartford
mansion this is the billiard room and
this is a great room we like to call up
the original man cave of course we have
a beautiful billiard table here this is
a great room because his friends would
come here they could you know play into
the evening into the late hours of
course Sam Clemens was a big fan of cats
and kittens and before you could play
pocket billiards she would have to go
around and check all the pockets and
make sure there were no furry critters
sleeping in them this was another fun
space because George Griffin the butler
would of course come upstairs from time
to time to announce the guests now the
guests in those days would bring their
little calling card and Sam would take
one look at the calling card and he
might say oh send him on up or he might
say I'll be right down
but he might say something different and
that was one he didn't really want to
see the person and he wouldn't lie
but he would go over to the little porch
on the side open the door and step out
onto that porch and tell George tell him
I just stepped out and that became known
as the stepping out porch but this SOB
this room is where he did his writing he
would coursework summers in Elmira and
write manuscript but he would come back
and sit here and we loved to welcome
visitors in the house period some of my
favorite 20 acts this is always their
favorite room and I think it's because
of the writing that happened here and we
have his writing desk in the corner back
there Sam knew himself he had to face
the wall to pay attention to his work
and not be distracted so he sat in the
corner to do his writing most of Mark
Twain's great books were written while
the family lived in this house so when
we come into this space yes we can
imagine him up here having his 40 cigars
a day hopefully just in this one place
with the doors open but maybe shooting a
game here with his friends or with
George Griffin the butler who was also a
close friend but we imagine him over
here in the corner piling up manuscript
as he called it and think of the books
that were written while the family were
here he wrote The Adventures of Tom
Sawyer he wrote Connecticut Yankee in
King Arthur's Court life on the
Mississippi
of course Adventures of Huckleberry Finn
and this is sort of sacred sacred ground
for a lot of people this is this is
where he would put the finishing touches
on and wrap it up and get it ready for
the publisher they traveled from this
house frequently while they lived here
but they would ultimately leave in 1891
what that means as they lived here for
17 years now they continued to own the
home for quite some time but the economy
was starting to go south
Sam had poured a lot of money into a at
one particular investment the page
compositor that took a toll on the
family's finances and the panic of 1893
of course put everybody against the
walls it was you know not dissimilar
from what we experienced in this country
in 2008 but in 1895 they set out on a
round-the-world lecture tour
now by now the girls were young adults
Sam and Livie and Clara the middle
daughter when
on this trip while Susie and Jean
meantime stayed in Elmira with their
aunt Susan they would come to Hartford
from time to time and be in the house
but they weren't really living in the
house at that point so this lecture tour
took a year finally when it ended they
sailed from South Africa to England
thinking they would rent quarters there
be reunited and decide where to go from
there
at that point they did send word to the
girls come on over you know where we're
off the road finally we can be reunited
well they received a cablegram back that
said Susy was ill they did expect a
quick recovery but they didn't think it
would be too quick Sam Clemens meantime
everyday waiting for news waiting for a
cablegram the cablegram did come it was
while his wife was halfway across the
Atlantic Ocean and it described Susy is
being peacefully released so Susy
Clemens died in this home at the age of
24 from spinal meningitis and it was a
very sad occasion as you can imagine the
family had a hard time recovering from
that they did recover from their
financial struggles but at what price
so to be away from those two daughters
for an entire year and then to lose Susy
was you know took quite a toll on them
after Susie's death
I think the family always aspired to
come back and live in Hartford but they
were so crushed and devastated by this
Mark Twain wrote to Livy and said the
calamity that comes is never the one we
had prepared ourselves for and he began
referring not to the City of Hartford
any longer but to the city of heartbreak
and that that was it they could no
longer live here they wanted to but they
just couldn't ring themselves to set
foot and come back when people come here
they hear this story of family a rising
star in our literary world and I think
people leave here understanding he was
just like the rest of us he was just a
guy wanting to raise his family give him
the best he could while making a
difference in the world you know he knew
his writing was was widely read and of
course the more famous he became and the
more he commented on problems around the
world the more his opinion was sought
and it's still valid when he when when
we hear of tragedies in the world today
you know we can we can pull up a Mark
Twain not just a quote not just some
throwaway clip but entire passages and
volumes that he wrote about the
challenges that we continue to face
today so I want people to leave here
feeling that they know him a little
better that he's more family to them
than they might think
all weekend American History TV is
featuring Hartford Connecticut during
the Civil War inventor and industrialist
Samuel Colt supplied firearms to both
the north and south from his Hartford
Factory hosted by our comcast Cable
partners c-span cities tour staff
recently visited many sites showcasing
the city's rich history learn more about
Hartford all weekend here on American
history TV
I just like getting up and coming to
this historic building and going to work
this building is interesting in and of
itself it's the only state capitol of
its type this is what would be called
high Victorian style built in the 1880s
a lot of the decorations in the internal
of the building are actually inspired by
what was popular at that moment so there
was a lot of studying of Morocco and of
northern Africa and if you look at some
of the tile floors in this building they
basically look like Moroccan rugs if you
look at the colors it's in keeping with
that popular style that was the 1880s
now a lot of the palettes on the walls
were also inspired by that history the
Victorians were studying other other
parts of the world and they were
incorporating that into their design so
this is a high Victorian Gothic
structure one of the other interesting
things about this building is when the
design and building team were chosen
instead of having the Capitol with a
dome the building was first envisioned
as having a clock tower now if it had
been built that way it'd be the only
State Capitol I think with a clock tower
but after the awarding of the contract
the state made the decision that we
should be more in line with other states
and and and have a dome the rest of
building is is full of history we're
standing in one of the halls of the
Capitol and Nathan half our state hero
who out of the words about having only
one life to give for his country which
he said at the time he was hung by the
British as a American spy he was a
schoolteacher
having completed his school year he
signed up to be a spy for George
Washington and he was captured in New
York City within 12 or 13 hours was put
to death by the British but those words
about having only one life to live and
to give for one's country have resonated
through
the centuries in American history
interestingly enough about Connecticut
we have a state here oh and we have a
state heroine she also was a teacher a
prudence Crandall a statue of her is
another another Hall of the of this
building and she opened the first school
for black girls in America and she
didn't get the best of treatment here in
Connecticut ultimately moved from
Connecticut it was a difficult moment in
our history but we recognized prudence
Crandall was as one as being well ahead
of her time being a teacher who stuck
her knuckle neck out for the good of the
broader society state hero state heroine
all of both our teachers this is a great
building for history the cannons at one
of the entrances our cannons had
actually fired on Richmond during the
Civil War
we have remnants of the battleship the
Hartford and that was an important ship
in the Civil War a period of time it was
on the decks of that ship that Admiral
Farragut uttered the words damn the
torpedoes full steam ahead now they
didn't have torpedoes as we think of
them as projectiles that go through the
water a torpedo then was a mine and so
he was saying damn the mines were going
in now this was a sailing ship that had
had a steam engine installed on it so we
have a model of that here but we also
have the bow ornament of of that ship in
the building it's quite ornate
interestingly enough that bow ornament
was incorporated into a Punchbowl design
for the battleship the Connecticut which
was Teddy Roosevelt's lead ship with a
great white fleet and the people of
Connecticut donated the silver set to
that to that ship you know III think
being the governor of Connecticut and
having moved to Hartford and living in
Hartford I'm excited every day about the
challenges of the job
I think Connecticut's going to continue
to be a leader
you know rubber was first manufactured
in Connecticut the cotton gin was
invented in Connecticut the first
practical helicopter was flown in
Connecticut in 1939 by Igor Sikorsky
himself an immigrant from Europe we're
going to continue to be a leader and
we're going to produce some pretty good
people and some pretty good products the
reality is that we are in a much slower
growth part of our history than we've
been in a long time as I stand here
somewhere between 27 and 35 States still
are not making as much revenue as they
did in 2008 adjusted for inflation we're
one of those places because the economy
is improving but it's been the slowest
improvement at any time in our history
since the Great Depression and so I
think a lot of folks expect that a
recovery to be just like the recoveries
of other recoveries in the post Second
World War period of time it is not so I
think what we're trying to do is drill
down and make sure that we're building a
connecticut that we can hand over to the
next generation that is better than the
one we got and quite frankly is
operating on a tighter budget and and
working more efficiently
all weekend American History TV is
featuring Hartford Connecticut the
birthplace of the Boys and Girls Club of
America in 1860 our comcast Cable
partners worked with c-span cities tour
staff when we travel to Hartford to
explore its rich history learn more
about Hartford all weekend here on
American history TV
Connecticut 50 objects 50 stories is an
exhibit that came together in 2015 when
we went all over the state and asked
people to send us images of objects that
represent stories that they feel define
Connecticut as a place as a people and
as an idea from those submissions we
then chose 50 that aren't the defining
stories of Connecticut but really helped
us to understand the complexity and the
depth of our history here the artifacts
that are on display here related to the
American Revolution really show how
Connecticut has played a role in most of
American history we didn't have a lot of
battles in Connecticut there were some
along the coastlines there was a raid on
Danbury but by and large we supplied the
Continental Army
we provided leadership we provided
support and Connecticut as a state
continues that role over the following
centuries a number of the items that we
have here at the Connecticut Historical
Society that are about the American
Revolution are here in our exhibit
Connecticut 50 objects and 50 stories
the first is Nathan Hales diary this is
an incredible piece Nathan Hale is
Connecticut State hero he was born in
Coventry and he was a farmer and a
schoolteacher but he joined the
Continental Army and he served with
Washington's troops outside of Boston he
volunteers on a spying mission and goes
down to New York at that time he was
caught and then he was hanged and he's
most known for his quote my only regret
is that I have only one life to give for
my country the Diary is really
incredible because it talks a lot about
everyday life and what it was like to be
in the Continental Army how people were
relating to each other what they were
thinking about what their concerns and
worries were what they did on a day to
day basis it really gives us a look at
what it was like to be a soldier in the
Continental Army the other piece we have
here is Munson Hoyts jacket he was one
of
one of the kinetic UNS who decided to
stay loyal to the crown about 20% of the
population of connecticut were loyalists
Hoyt served in the revolution he served
the British crown and he fought against
the Revolutionary Army after his time
served in the military he then left and
he was he moved to Canada to New
Brunswick where he became a merchant and
he actually co-owned a business with
Benedict Arnold until it burned down and
there was some disagreement in their
business relationship later he marries a
woman from Long Island and eventually
dies in about 1805 there's just some
really compelling stories here in
Connecticut about loyalists and why they
remain loyal instead of joining the
Continental Army or wanting independence
from the British government and Munson
was just one of those characters but we
have so many others in the collection if
you go into our archive and library you
can read diaries about other loyalists
and what they were thinking and why they
wanted to stay with the British
government whether that was for economic
purposes whether that was about their
identity or just even their future plans
the amount of information we have and
collections and objects related to the
American Revolution is is actually quite
large because we were founded to save
that history we have furniture from the
period we have textiles we have prints
we have books diaries letters the
Connecticut Historical Society often
runs behind the scene tours and they're
a fantastic opportunity to show members
of the public items that are in our
collection this is the waistcoat of
Colonel William Leonard he was the
commander at Fort Griswold and grant in
Connecticut my story behind this is that
on September 6 1781 there was an attack
by British ships someone at the fort
noticed the enemy flag and reported it
and so the idea was to fire off two
shots which marked enemies approaching
the infamous Benedict Arnold was on one
of the approaching British ships and he
knew that this is what they're supposed
to do so he fired a third shot which
typically
that friendlies were approaching this
accounts for why there was slow
reinforcements to come to the fort so
the British attacked the fort they
eventually won out and the story goes
that Colonel ed Yard offered over his
sword to a British general to surrender
and then that general actually stabbed
led yard which accounts for the holes in
the waistcoat killing him along with the
punctured marks there were originally
blood stains from William Leonard on the
waistcoat however when it was given to
the CHS in 1841 it was decided that the
blood stains were too gruesome for the
ladies so they were actually washed out
of the waistcoat which if you ask any
historian or archivists or collections
person now they would probably grimace
at the thought so the second article
that we've taken out is the cloak of
Deborah champion she was 22 years old
from New London Connecticut and her
father Henry was the commissary general
for the Patriots and he was trying to
send messages to George Washington who
is stationed at Boston at the time and
originally he wanted to send his son
Henry but thought that he would get
stopped more easily so he sent his
daughter Deborah and she was actually
wearing this cloak when she was sneaking
messages past the British and she would
wear this cloak and she would hide the
messages within her bodice and she also
wore it's called the Kailash it's a bit
like a large bonnet and she didn't want
to wear it at first but her mother
insisted that she did and later she
remarked that it was a good thing she
did because she was able to pull it over
her head as she was stopped by loyalist
officers and they just remark that she
was an old lady and that she could pass
through and she later wrote a letter to
her friend patience telling about her
tales while she was writing it her
father had come in and said to make sure
she didn't give away any sort of details
as to where George Washington was
stationed or anything she had heard on
his whereabouts
and numbers so our final object that
we're showing today is a flag from the
second Connecticut regiment it is the
last Connecticut infantry color flag
left in existence that we know of many
people question its authenticity yes
because of its color most flags for the
Connecticut second regiment were blue at
that time and this is obviously a deep
red and they actually think it was an
earlier Connecticut militia flag and
that they had just continued to use it
during the American Revolution the flag
is assumed to be made out of silk with
metallic dye which is a part of the
reason that it's so withered not only
because of time but because the metallic
dye would have eaten away at the silk
it's preserved in two pieces of mesh and
then suspended one of the reasons that
the Connecticut Historical Society has
so many of these Revolutionary War era
artifacts is because we were founded in
1825 we were founded just the year
before the 50th anniversary of the
American Revolution and we were founded
because the men and women of Connecticut
felt like we were losing our history
from that period that it was
disappearing that it was being scattered
amongst people's homes and their own
personal collections and so they wanted
to create institutions like the CHS
where you could bring those materials
together so they could be preserved they
could be shared and that we could learn
from them for future generations
so now 190 years later we're able to
pull out items like this red coat like
Nathan's Hales diary like a flag from
the Revolution and so many other
materials that that continue to tell us
new stories that we hadn't known in the
past about periods that really helped us
become who we are today
Oh weekend American history TV is
featuring Hartford Connecticut located
in the middle of the state
Hartford began as a trading post on the
Connecticut River in the 1600s the town
was incorporated in 1784 c-span's cities
tour staff recently visited many sites
showcasing the city's history learn more
about Hartford all weekend here on
American history TV we're in the main
branch of the Hartford Public Library
right outside the Hartford History
Center right now we have in the exhibit
up of making freedom the life of venture
Smith because we're celebrating the
250th anniversary of venture regaining
his freedom and Hartford is the place in
1760 where venture Smith as a slave was
pawn to Daniel Edwards and learned to
read on the two hundred and fiftieth it
seemed symbolic to have the exhibit here
in Hartford the State Capitol what we're
looking at here is the cover of this
great autobiography written by venture
Smith in 1798
and this is the family copy from the
binary library at Yale University this
is the earliest known african-american
literary voice and it's one of the great
masterpieces of American literature
venture starts his life in West Africa
near what is today Lake of Chad in a
place called oh and gara ventures people
were known as herders his father was the
king or the chief of this area it was a
fairly wealthy place they had a lot of
gold their venture was being raised to
become the ruler of his people so by age
10 or 11 he had already had extensive
education and then a regen come army
comes
and captures them and one of the searing
moments and ventures life is watching
his father be tortured to death to try
and find the gold and wealth of his
people they then take venture from his
home as I say about eleven and March him
typical over a thousand miles from the
interior of West Africa down to the Gold
Coast where he's put into a castle and
ultimately rode out venture was bought
by this one of the officers of the
steward this gives you a sense of what a
human being could be worth he was bought
for four gallons of rum and a piece of
calico and and transformed from being a
a human being into a commodity to be
bought sold and traded this is the great
horrors of the Atlantic slave trade this
Rhode Island slave ship leaves on a mob
ooh and it's headed back and it leaves
wood then the Gold Coast or Ghana today
and sails across the Atlantic to
Barbados the eastern most of the British
sugar plantation islands and at that
time in 1739 one of the very richest
places on the face of the earth
venture fortunately is being raised by
Robinson Mumford to become his steward
or manservant so at this point he's
already on the ship being given some
education once the ship makes it back to
its homeport in Newport Rhode Island
venture oh this eleven-year-old has put
with the sister of his owner to learn
English to learn how to be a manservant
how to live in the colonial culture and
he spends a year or so there and then is
taken to fishers island where
he's a slave from about 1740 41 to the
end of 1754 owned by the mum fruits well
on fishers island venture marries his
wife made we know nothing about her
except for this wonderful phrase I
married her for love
as soon as venture gets married all of a
sudden the the quest for freedom really
comes alive in him and that's why this
whole story of his life is always about
freedom and ventures desires to
recapture the freedom that he had as a
child growing up in Africa the Mumford's
then sell venture to Thomas Stanton on
place called Stonington point on the
mainland this is clearly for the next
four years ventures owner that he has
the worst time with and gets on the
worst after four years there the Stanton
sell him to a local just broker who
brings venture here to Hartford and
instead of selling him he pawns him for
one year for ten pounds to a noted
attorney and judge in Hartford this is
the period and this is Daniel Edwards
this is the point where venture is
obviously exposed to a sophisticated
household to a very educated man who
would have taught him to read and who
challenges venture to go home and build
a future for his wife and family
so in 1760 venture gets sold to his last
owner a young merchant Oliver Smith who
was from Groton just moved to Stonington
and who was building a house he buys
venture this great big strong man to
build his house and his business and
housed that venture helps bill and
Oliver Smith moves into in 1761 is still
standing in Stonington Venture Labor's
day and night to accumulate enough money
between 1760 when he comes to Stonington
in 1765 Smith has agreed to sell them in
essence to sell venture to himself for
85 pounds as venture said my my freedom
is a privilege which nothing else can
equal he's bought his freedom in 1765
and that's why this year we are
celebrating the 250th of this great
event we're in the Hartford History
Center now and this is fittingly where
we're telling the story of ventures
success and building a whole family in a
dynasty this panel talks about real
estate which venture starts to
accumulate in the spring of 1775 and
real estate at the time of the New
Republic of the revolution was a symbol
of freedom at his peak venture owns more
than a hundred and thirty acres which is
very large farm he has a dry dock
shipping works and he's he's become this
person that was brought to America as a
traded commodity has become a trader in
commodities and becomes very wealthy and
then in 1798 near the end of his life he
actually writes this great autobiography
which tells us all everything he did who
he was where he was from and it's one of
the only works that actually talks of
talks about of birth in Africa describes
it the middle passage and then slavery
and ultimately freedom in New England
across the Salmon River in the town of
East Haddam venture made his life
busting his most important real estate
trance action he bought a family plot in
the First Congregational Church of East
Haddam
which at that point was one of the elite
burial grounds in all of Connecticut and
he had himself and his wife and his son
Solomon and his granddaughter and two
grandchildren are all buried in the
family plot most important though is
this is ventures tombstone carved by
John ISM jr. and on it he he put in very
simple things sacred to the memory of
venture Smith an African though the son
of a king he was kidnapped and sold as a
slave but by his industry he acquired
money to purchase his freedom who died
September 19 1805 in the 77th year of
his age venture set out to be remembered
by writing his autobiography and by the
tombstone and for his family to have a
dynasty or a legacy all of his owners
who were prominent people in the 18th
century have been forgotten ventures
narrative today is still in print all
weekend American history TV is featuring
Hartford Connecticut Samuel Clemens more
commonly known as Mark Twain lived in
Hartford while writing The Adventures of
Tom Sawyer and The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn c-span cities tour
staff recently visited many sites
showcasing the city's history learn more
about Hartford all weekend here on
American history TV
here we are in nineteenth-century author
Harriet Beecher Stowe's home in Hartford
Connecticut on Forest Street and
Hartford Connecticut and we invite you
to visit and we are standing today in
Stowe's parlor her front parlor the more
formal space when you visit here you sit
down in this parlor and share
conversation about issues and
experiences Stowe was born Harriet
Beecher in 1811 in Litchfield
Connecticut in western Connecticut and
then through her life she lived at
Boston Cincinnati Brunswick Maine for a
couple of years and over mass and then
she and her husband retired to be near
her two sisters here in Hartford
Connecticut and in Hartford they had two
houses first in the middle of the Civil
War Stowe built her dream house her
glamorous mansion and they built that
house and moved in in 1863 and lived
there for about eight years and then
discovered over those years that it was
too expensive to maintain
so they downsized into this more modest
though still spacious Hartford home
where they lived out the rest of her of
their lives so Stowe moved into this
fourth Street house in Hartford in 1873
and the house had been built on spec and
lived in for a couple of years so it she
didn't specially build it she did she
moved into it as she had with most of
the homes she lived in her life she
moved in with her husband Calvin Stowe
whom she'd married in 1836 and he was
about 10 years older than her and he was
a professor of theology and he was
retired and she moved in with her oldest
children twin girls her adult daughters
and they were in their 30s Stowe was in
her 60s and her husband Calvin was in
his 70s and Stowe was still writing she
was she was world famous she had reached
that pinnacle of fame in her 40s and now
she's in her 60s and she's still writing
to support the family so she did some
books in this house and many many
articles an opinion piece
Harriet Beecher Stowe's house is a
domestic environment another one of the
things she wrote about was how to manage
your household and she thought and wrote
a lot about how women should she helped
advance the idea that managing your
house and thinking about the kind of
domestic environment you built made a
better family and made a better America
so this house reflects that it is not
just one design but it certainly
reflects the aesthetic movement of the
19th century as it's called and but it's
also a house that reflects that these
people had had long lives and had deep
family connections so it's it's familial
it's friendly it's comfortable it's used
we work hard as a museum not to have it
be too tidy so there might be some as a
the writers table some crumpled papers
on the floor and things like that we
want to evoke a home that is lived in
it's not pristine it's a it's a home
that was lived in and sitting down with
Harriet Beecher Stowe I think from her
writings and other people's reports I
think she was a quiet person I think she
was an introvert and so there's a lot
going on in her head and people said
things like you would think she wasn't
paying attention to the conversation but
then she would start to fully
participate in what had been happening
was she'd been thinking about characters
or stories that were gonna come out
later in her books so she hold she held
things in her head for 20 or 30 years
before they came out in her writing so
talking with there might have been an
interesting experience because she was
thinking about two things at once the
conversation and her characters and what
she was going to be writing another way
people described her is that she wasn't
a particularly attractive person until
she became animated in the conversation
and then there was a sort of light about
her and charisma and personality that
you didn't see when she wasn't Anna
and you can see that in the photographs
and in the physical evidence we have
like sculptures and cameos and things
that portray her that she you know might
not have met the beauty standards of the
day few of us do after all but that her
character and personality brought that
to the foreign made her great company
and of course Harriet Beecher Stowe was
really smart and articulate and she was
taught at her father's dining table to
make the case for her argument Harriet
Beecher Stowe's home in Hartford is a
classic Victorian environment with two
parlors and dining room downstairs and a
kitchen which of course wouldn't been a
public space and bedrooms upstairs and
when you visit you see those spaces and
in the parlors you see the environment
as much as it was when Stowe lived here
as we can tell from our research and
from a few photographs we have we're
lucky enough to have a lot of
possessions that Stowe owned and that
were owned by her extended family we ask
people to journey through the house with
us we talk about the past as well as the
present so trying to despoil the explain
Stowe's long life and her impact and
when you reach the front parlor you sit
down in chairs in the front parlor with
the other people of your tour and you
have a conversation about artifacts on
this table that represent the issues of
the 19th century you pass these copies
of artifacts around you discuss them
when you go into onto the second floor
you one of the rooms you go into is
Stowe's bedroom which is of course her
bedroom but is also one of the places
she wrote so it is set up with writing
space and evidence of what it took of
the struggles she had to write her books
particularly Uncle Tom's Cabin so that's
just a little bit of a glimpse into some
of the experiences that you can have
here
we're in Harriet's front parlor right
now which in a lot of ways would have
been the face of this house
so when Harriet was formally receiving
guests she'd quickly ushered them into
this room and began you know talking to
them about a whole host of issues that
she was passionate about so here we have
a photograph of Harriet Beecher Stowe's
sitting in her front parlor where we are
um so she's sitting right about where
I'm standing now and you can really get
a feel for what the room looked like at
the time I also get a feel for what
Harriet looked like so what we're gonna
try to do is talk about some documents
that she may have been seeing in the
1850s when she's coming up with the
ideas for Uncle Tom's Cabin and in a lot
of ways these document represents the
debates that people were having over
slavery at the time so on this table
here we have some historical documents
that we've reproduced for our visitors
we really want to give our visitors a
feel for the debates over slavery that
were occurring during Harriet's time so
for example we have some reward posters
for fugitive slaves that may have been
found in the north at the time we have
songs written by abolitionists that
would have been sung at different
meetings and of abolitionists then we
even have teaching tools for
abolitionists children so this for
example kind of gives you a feel for the
alphabet but also gives you a poem
attached to each letter that talks about
some negative aspect of slavery so these
sort of things were very effective
teaching tools at the time now even more
than that we have photos that would have
been circulated in northern newspapers
to try to gain support for abolitionism
so for example this is a photo here of
emancipated slaves that would have been
found in northern newspapers quite a bit
after the Fugitive Slave Law has passed
so the back parlor here would have been
more of a private family space where
Harriet would have spent time with her
husband and her two twin daughters
living here they may be reading to each
other they may be writing letters they
may be playing the piano but it was more
of a relaxation space than a public
formal entertaining space
so when visitors come into this room we
don't allow them to touch
anything or to sit on any of the chairs
although we have reproduced the circular
letter again which sometimes will pass
around and show to visitors so now that
we've seen Harriet's back parlor we'll
even go into a more private space
Harriet's bedroom so here we are in
Harriet's bedroom and we have a lot of
items in this room that give you a feel
for what Harriet's writing process was
like and what the aftermath of the
publication of Uncle Tom's Cabin was
like for her as well so in terms of her
writing process you can see over here
that as I mentioned Harriet really
didn't have a dedicated writing space in
this house we know that she would have
been writing quite a bit in this room
her bedroom and that she was not always
the neatest writer when it was going on
so we've have some papers littered here
to just give you a feel for what the
room would have looked like as Harriet's
writing so over on this bed here we have
an enlarged reproduction of a newspaper
called the national era so when Uncle
Tom's Cabin came out it didn't really
come out in book form for quite a bit it
was originally serialized in an
abolitionist newspaper called the
National era from Washington DC so every
Wednesday a new chapter of Uncle Tom's
Cabin would come out and people would
gather in each other's parlors and hear
it being read aloud so over here we have
a portrait of Harriet's husband Calvin
Stowe and Calvin was an incredibly
supportive force in Harriet's life
throughout her writing process you know
he was willing to do many things that
would not have been considered unusual
for men to do at the time for example he
would you know take care of the kids in
the house so that Harriet would have
enough time to be able to write her book
now again this would have been
considered very unusual for the time but
it's just one of the many ways that that
Harriet chose write with Calvin so these
are a selection of works that Harriet
wrote while she's living in this house
and we really like to show our visitors
some other works besides Uncle Tom cabin
that that Harriet Beecher Stowe is known
for we're really trying to let our
visitors know that Harriet has made a
lasting impact and that we really want
to make sure her story is not forgotten
well Stowe died
1896 she was 85 she died in this house
as her husband had before her and when
she died this parlor were standing in
the front parlor her coffin was laid out
here and this is where the wake was so
the New York Times wrote this up it was
widely reported and she was so famous
that many came to visit and give their
respects she was buried next to one of
her children well two of her children
who predeceased her and her husband in
Andover Massachusetts where they had
been living when their son Henry died at
19 so they bought a family plot there so
you can visit the grave and end over
Massachusetts near where Calvin Stowe
worked at Andover Theological Seminary
Harry Beecher Stowe's legacy today both
reflects her writing in the 19th century
and her impact then with Uncle Tom's
Cabin and many other books that she
wrote and the stands that she took as a
woman and let's remember that in the
19th century women couldn't vote and
that they had limited roles whatever
their class or race they were restricted
and she took the most advantage that she
could of the opportunities she had as a
woman in the 19th century
she made her name she made her points
and she argued forcefully for them and
then she leveraged that to make things
happen in the 21st century all of that
is important because much of her writing
whether it's about domestic life or
about slavery itself gives us framework
for today because the past informs the
present and here we are today in the
21st century still struggling deeply in
the headlines and in our homes and in
our friendships and in our workplaces
with the many things that Stowe was
writing about that they were struggling
with then and when you come to visit
Harriet Beecher Stowe's house you're
going to have an experience unlike many
other historic House Museum all weekend
long American history TV is joining our
comcast cable partners to showcase the
history of Hartford Connecticut
to learn more about the cities on our
current tour visit c-span org slash
cities tour we continue now with our
look at the history of Hartford
welcome to Bushnell Park we are looking
at the beautiful soldiers and sailors
Memorial arch dedicated to the 4,000 men
from Hartford who fought in the Civil
War in 1860 parkford was a city of
29,000 residents that tells us in
Hartford
everyone knew someone who fought in the
Civil War
probably everyone knew someone who died
or came back badly wounded I believe
that the founders of Hartford were
really looking to make a statement when
they designed this amazing arch the arch
was designed by a local architect named
of George Keller very prominent in
Connecticut and statewide and did many
national commissions as well he was an
immigrant from Cork with his family to
New York City and then at the age of 23
moved to Hartford to work for the
Batterson Memorial Company he involved
several sculptors in this arch because
he really wanted it to tell a story
there is a beautiful frieze made of
terracotta the frieze stretches 160 feet
all the way around on both sides and
there were two different artists
involved in designing it the woman in
the middle of the frieze is an
allegorical figure representing the City
of Hartford under the lady in the middle
are some words in Latin post-new Beulah
Phoebus after the darkness the Sun that
is the motto of the City of Hartford
since its founding this is the side of
the frieze that is facing south saying
welcome home welcome back from the war
on this side of the arch we see the
soldiers returning home many of them
badly wounded
I'm being carried it's a scene of joy
and of sadness on the north side of the
arch is a second frieze by a different
sculptor his name was Samuel Kitson from
England this frieze shows what kind of a
war what kind of battle the Civil War
soldiers and sailors faced it was
immediate face-to-face torturous bloody
combat there is one historical face on
the arch on horseback we see the figure
of ulysses s grant General Grant that is
the only face that we we know is
historically accurate we don't know who
all the others are one of my favorite
things about the arch is that George
Keller wanted to note that this was a
citizen army and this art shows those
lucky ones who were able to get back and
put down their items of war and take up
their trade so we can identify each one
of these as returning to his trade the
carpenter you can see down his left leg
there is a saw not easy to carve a saw
out of stone on this side on the east
tower is the stonemason you can see that
he's got a trowel in his hand and I
think most importantly behind him we can
see the Union Army jacket and you can
even see every tiny button this one is
returning to academia
he has his cap and is down and he's able
to discard his military kit bag
and go back to being a scholar this
fellow is the blacksmith he was
travelling with the cavalry he has a
cavalry sword in his right hand which he
can now discard and take up his trade
and this is the farmer looking behind
him we can see an image of some wheat
and his kit bag that he will be able to
finally leave behind him George Keller
the architect originally wanted to
include a statue of a merchant as the
sixth statue on the tower but sometime
in those six years before the statues
actually were placed on the arch he
changed his mind and did something very
interesting he decided that the sixth
statue would not be a merchant but it
would be a freed slave this is the one
statue where the person is not returning
to their trade or profession or job of
before the war this freed slave of
course was freed in the course of the
war I want to tell you about this plaque
that was added to the arch in 1988 a 7th
grade boy was very interested and
actually concerned that the only image
of a black person on the arch was the
freed slave he knew that there were free
blacks living in Hartford at the time of
the civil war and that some of them had
probably fought he did original research
and he identified the names of 128 free
blacks from Hartford who fought in the
Civil War in 1988 when rededicating they
arch they included this plaque for the
rededication and they especially
rededicated it to Hartford's 128 black
soldiers who were not previously honored
for their bravery in val
in the great Civil War if we go
96 steps one of the things that we'd
love to talk about at the top of the
arch are the two angels we have Gabriel
blowing the trumpet and Raphael with the
cymbals angels were a very popular
Victorian decoration we believe that
Gabriel was is there to represent the
day of judgment and Raphael the
resurrection the afterlife
another thing we like to show folks from
up here are the beautiful views this is
our state capitol the Capitol building
was built in 1878 the arch is one of the
iconic images of Hartford for us